Let's buildup our linear model for price. I'm
going to store the first model in a variable called
m1. You probably also noticed how I used the
I wrapper around each of the variables. The I
stands for as is. In this case, it tells
R to use the expression inside the I function
to transform a variable before using it in the
regression. This is instead of instructing R to interpret
these symbols as part of the formula to construct
the design matrix for the regression. You can read more
about the syntax for linear models in the instructor
notes. I can also update the previous model to add
the caret variable in the regression, using the syntax.
The real functional relationship is surely not as simple as
the cubed root of caret, so we add a
simple linear function of caret in our model predicting price.
And we can continue to make more complex models by
adding more variables. We add cut even though we don't
expect it to have much influence on price. Next, we
add color to a fourth model and clarity to a
fifth. When we run the code, we can see that
we're getting some very nice R square values. We're accounting
for almost all of the variance in price using the
four Cs. If we want to know whether the price for,
a diamond is reasonable, we might now use this model.